I'm going to bar model a basic ratio
problem for you
we'll start by reading the question all
the way through then we're going to
rewrite the question in the form of a
sentence so the students know where
they're trying to end up I've put a
demarcation here to give some structure
to the students on the right-hand side
they'll put their arithmetic on the
left-hand side they'll put their bar
model so we'll read it all the way
through answer sentence then we're gonna
we're gonna read back through we're
going to stop where we can draw
something draw a bar in particular so
let's go ahead and begin a teacher has
20 ungraded papers she has four times as
many in graded papers as ungraded papers
good for her
how many graded papers are there so
we're gonna rewrite the question in the
form of a sense there are blank graded
papers okay now we're going to read back
through and stop where we can draw a bar
or something a teacher has 20 ungraded
papers so we have ungraded we know that
that is represented by 20 the quantity
of 20 a bar she has four times as many
graded papers so we have graded and four
times as many means that I'm going to
have four of these
how many graded papers are there so we
are looking for the total number of
graded papers now notice this is a a
problem where you're going to have to
elaborate a little bit you're going to
have to understand that this is one unit
and this is one unit so this is also
going to be twenty so students from
there can say that twenty times four is
equal to the same thing as two times
four times ten or just let's keep it
simple
twenty times four is eighty so there are
eighty graded papers you can elaborate
on this a little bit more so if you're
wanting to challenge your students you
can ask them how many more how many more
graded papers are there than ungraded
papers so make the most of your bar
model opportunity here but we'll leave
that for another time